in his interview with Tim Ferris nval
rant reveals that the secret to his
writing is contained in a single blog
post even though I am a very good writer
and I've been writing a lot since I was
young I still open up that blog post and
I put it in the background anytime I'm
writing anything that's important it's
that good I use it I use it as my basic
template for how to write well and the
best part is the blog post is only 250
words long but packed into those few
words is a ton of value so in today's
video I'm going to reveal three key
insights that helped nval become one of
the most successful writers on the web
and that will hopefully help you write
more persuasively trigger your reader
curiosity and use language to hack your
reader psychology and bring your writing
to life if you consider yourself to not
be a great writer if you not a 10 out of
10 writer already or nine out of 10
already that that one blog post right
there will change your writing style
forever welcome back to WR science the
channel where we explore the Art and
Science of expert writing if you're new
here I'm William and I'm an English
Professor based in South Korea and the
blog post that made nval such a
successful writer is titled the day you
became a better writer and it was
written by Scott Adams and the first
lesson from that blog post comes from
the author's training as a hypnotist now
in case you don't know Scott Adams is a
master of persuasive language and
persuasion is according to Adams the key
to business writing but it's not really
helpful to say write more persuasively
because writing persuasively is one of
those things that sounds simple but is
not easy so in the blog post Scott Adams
clarifies what it means to use
persuasion in writing according to Adams
the key to persuasive writing is Kill
Your Darlings now that's not exactly the
phrase that Adams uses but let me show
you what I mean the problem that Adams
fixes here is that in practice many
writers become too attached to the early
drafts of their writing and they don't
like the idea that those early drafts
contain extra words that can be cut
without changing their meaning consider
the difference between these two
sentences he was very happy and he was
happy now of course these sentences
don't mean exactly the same thing and
you can imagine a writer saying that the
very in the first sentence isn't extra
it adds important meaning to which Scott
Adams replies you think the word very
adds something it doesn't the main
technique is keeping things simple
simple writing is persuasive now of
course the advice to keep your writing
simple is nothing new you can find some
version of it in almost every guide or
rules of writing but in explaining
simple writing style Adams draws our
attention to the sentence level simple
means according to Adams getting rid of
extra words so just like a gardener
who's pulling out weeds and pruning
leaves so that the stronger branches can
flower and grow a persuasive writer is
one who prunes their draft removing all
unnecessary words to let the most
important parts come through and of
course that's why the blog post is only
250 words long but it's also why Nal is
so successful on X because if you can
express an idea in a simple phrase such
as Kill Your Darlings then it's bound to
stick now we can see the second Insight
at work in the title of the blog post
itself the day you became a better
writer it's kind of weird isn't it I
mean if you were going to write this
article what would you expect the title
to be probably something like how to
write persuasively or three tips about
business writing but that title is
really interesting because it prompts
the reader to ask thems a few questions
when was it that I became a better
writer how can I become a better writer
who is even telling this story these
questions are known as curiosity Loops
which are what happens when the reader
realizes that there's something they
don't understand and by peing our
curiosity like that Adams practically
forces us to open the blog post so in
that simple title alone there are two
key lessons first the first line of your
piece is not the first line it's the
headline a lot of writers treat the
title like some parking lot that they
need to fill up with keywords something
which tells the reader exactly what the
piece is going to be about and that's
fairly logical but giving it all away in
the title fails to trigger the reader's
curiosity because it doesn't open up any
curiosity Loops it basically just opens
up the kimono and shows the reader
everything that's inside and that's the
second point that even before the
opening line the headline itself needs
to trigger curiosity that's the feeling
that makes us binge on TV shows and
detective novels and to use it in your
own writing here are four strategies for
triggering curiosity and why don't you
see if you can figure out which one of
these strategies Adams uses in the title
the day you became a better writer first
pose a question or an incomplete puzzle
second signal that someone else
possesses knowledge that they are
missing third violate their expectations
to trigger a search for an explanation
and fourth expose them to a sequence of
events with an anticipated but unknown
resolution so now we see what makes the
title of that blog post so compelling
it's designed to surprise anyone who
already has the desire to become a
better writer and by violating the
reader expectations in that way by
saying the day you became a better
writer it makes the reader feel like
there's something missing that they
don't know and that they really want to
find out which brings us on to the third
point which I absolutely love because it
uses a clever grammar trick to activate
the visual part of your reader's brain
and this is so powerful because it gets
to the heart of good writing which is
care care ful attention to the reader
and their psychology and unfortunately
writers who don't understand this point
wind up writing flabby lifeless
sentences this is when Adams tells us to
learn how brains organize ideas and to
show you how this works let me ask you
this which one of these sentences is
easier to understand the boy hit the
ball the ball was hit by the boy now yes
both sentences mean the same thing they
use the same nouns they use the same
verbs they use the same tense but I
think many people would agree that the
first one is easier to understand why is
that well that's because the sentence
uses a certain structure which is known
in grammar as the active voice whereas
the second one is written in the passive
voice now the passive voice is actually
a pretty controversial topic when it
comes to writers yes writers actually
get pretty worked up about these sorts
of things so much so that there are many
writing guides that warn writers that
the passive voice should never be used
so to understand the two big problems
that are caused by the passive voice we
first need to understand what it is all
right so in language there are basically
two levels of meaning you've got syntax
which is like subject verb and then the
object okay but you've also got this
second layer called semantics which is
basically just means meaning and the
thing about syntax is that it's fixed in
English the order is always going to be
subject verb complement or object but at
the level of semantics these things can
be moved around so you've got the agent
which is the thing that performs the
action of the verb then there's a
process which is the verb and then
there's the goal which is the thing that
receives the action of the verb now in
normal sentence structure with normal
syntax we find the agent in the place of
the subject the process is of course in
the verb and the goal is over here in
the object but the passive voice
switches these things around so you get
the goal over here in the subject
position and the agent goes over here in
a prepositional phrase so those are the
two problems caused by the passive voice
first the passive voice puts the agent
way over here at the end of the sentence
in a prepositional by phrase and it puts
the goal which is the thing that
receives the action of the verb in the
subject position and since we read from
left to right the passive voice sets up
a sequence in which the reader first
encounters the goal and then the action
and then only at the end of the sentence
do they find the actor so the reader is
expecting to see the agent the thing
that does the verb over here in the
subject position but in the passive
voice the reader has to wait until the
end of the sentence before they even
find out who is performing the action of
the verb and that's really hard to
imagine because actions are not out
there happening on their own there are
agents who are performing those actions
so if I write to you in the passive
voice you can't actually picture what
I'm talking about until you get to the
end of the sentence but the second
problem caused by the passive voice is
even more important because look at what
it does to the verb with the active
voice we've just got the verb is matched
up with the process it's right here but
if you want to make the passive voice
you actually have to shift the action
out of the verb phrase you need to
introduce the verb be the passive voice
is always the verb be plus the past
participle so the passive voice makes an
emphasis not on the action but on this
flabby B verb and that's such a boring
verb like we use the verb to be in order
to describe or Define something so with
the passive voice you're taking the life
and the energy out of your sentence
putting it over here in this past
participle and you're making the focus
this lousy be verb in effect the passive
voice sort of sucks the life out of the
sentence but Adam's point is not just
about the active voice and the passive
voice that was just an example later on
in the section about reader psychology
he says all brains work that way notice
I didn't say that is the way all brains
work all brains work that way is easier
to understand because you've got the
agent over here in the subject position
and the action in the verb but when it
comes to the second sentence that is the
way that all brains work what have you
got well in the subject position we
don't have a character but we've got a
pronoun which is referring to an
abstract idea and the verb again is not
an action but one of these boring be
verbs verbs so the same principle
applies our readers want characters in
the subject position and actions in
verbs that is easier to picture it
activates the visual part of our brain
so unless you have a very good reason to
use the passive voice and there are some
really good reasons just so we're clear
about that then you should always
default to the active voice but this
advice about the passive voice is going
to give a lot of writers the wrong idea
about the active voice and the passive
voice I'm afraid that many will take it
as a hard rule to never use the passive
voice and that is not the point the
author David Foster Wallace has a great
point about teaching the passive voice
he said it's really tricky because if
you say to students never use the
passive voice you're an idiot sometimes
the passive voice is exactly what you
want but not all the time and probably
not more than 5% of sentences really
need to be in the passive voice so
before you take it as a hard rule to
never use the passive voice it's
important to remember that languages are
organisms they're always evolving
they're always adapting and they're
always trying to become more efficient
so just like any organism a language is
not going to keep a word or a grammar
form that doesn't have some important
function and the passive voice is an
important tool in every writer's toolkit
so the day you understood how to use the
passive voice effectively is the day you
watch this video right here because it's
going to teach you how to stop following
useless writing rules like never use the
passive voice and start making active
decisions about your own writing so be
sure to go check it out